hello so recently i've gone through the
grades of people like einstein and
nicola tesla
and on those videos some of you asked
that i show some of my own grades
and i thought well today as a bit of a
special video to celebrate
passing 500k subscribers then i would do
just that so i'm going to show you
through the transcript i have here
of my time at the university of
canterbury which is where i did my
undergraduate degree and it was a
bachelor of science
majoring in physics and maths i'll put
the university grading scale up on the
screen
so you can have a little look it goes
from an a plus
which means you got a mark of between 90
and 100 for the course
all the way down to an e and i think
anything above
a d would be considered a passing grade
there are then a couple of special
grades such as p
and f which are usually for things that
aren't worth credit or are considered
differently to an actual course
so let's start with 2013 which was my
first year of uni
and the year is broken up into two main
semesters
and to be considered a full-time student
you would take
four courses in each semester each
course is worth 15 points
so if you keep that up over three years
you would have the 360 points that you
need
to graduate now i'll highlight the
courses that i took
during my first semester which is when i
was 17.
i got two a pluses and a and
an a minus now this was probably one of
my best semesters
at uni because i was fresh out of high
school i was motivated i was pretty hard
working
and i was fairly organized so much so
that i
do remember actually reading and
studying
some of the lecture materials before
showing up to the lecture
which is a good practice but
unfortunately not something that i was
able to keep up for very long
i took courses in math physics
astrophysics
and computer science now of those the
computer science course was definitely
the most difficult for me
and i think that's because i had never
encountered computer science before
this class was my first introduction to
any of the concepts of coding
so first semester was fine but second
semester would go on to probably be my
worst semester of my degree
it was one where i felt stressed a lot
of the time
i was disorganized i would show up to
lectures late
i had this one class that i really hated
which was math 170
and maybe i hated it because i didn't
really have any friends
in that class or i don't know why but i
remember
when the exam time came around i just
felt like i couldn't focus i couldn't
focus on studying
i showed up to the exam and asked
someone as we were waiting outside the
door to be let in to explain bayes
theorem to me
you know that's how last minute i was
kind of panicking about this
whole semester at the same time i was
taking part in this university business
competition
and trying to launch a startup and i was
also working on some other projects
to do with the video interviews and
things for the physics department
a couple of notes is that this academic
writing assessment wasn't a course it
was just
a little test we had to do to prove we
were proficient at
writing and this astro
2-1-1 the two indicates that it was a
second year course whereas all of the
others would be considered first-year
courses so that's kind of reflecting
their difficulty
so let's move on to my second year and
you may notice here that i've taken
10 courses instead of the usual eight
and there's no real reason why i've done
that and in fact i ended up getting a
lot more
points and i needed to graduate so you
wouldn't
do this as a strategic option i guess
but the extra courses that i added were
ones that i really wanted to take
and so i felt prepared to do extra work
in both semesters to be able to take
them
i did all the standard courses in maths
and physics
and then i added this science
communication
third year course which i guess kind of
makes sense to what i do now i was
interested in science communication back
then and i also added on this
first year computer science course which
was a follow-up to the one i'd taken in
first year
and i kid you not i decided to take that
course
just because i had a dream about it i
had a dream about
one day before the deadline to sign up
for courses
that i had taken this course and that i
don't know there was just this feeling
that it was the right thing to do
so i woke up and i enrolled in it but i
actually was really glad about that
decision
it was a course all about sort of
algorithms and data structures
and in the internship that i did at the
end of this second year
i was in an observatory and we were
processing images of galaxies
the skills that i learned in that class
were pretty much the most useful thing
i'd learned
all year in terms of you know how to
process these images using code
the grades this year were pretty good i
got quite a few a
pluses and no b's which i was happy
about of these courses the hardest one
was probably analysis and groups math
240.
but the one that required the most work
was probably fizz 285
experimental physics which i managed to
get an a plus in
but it took a lot of work because it was
a lab course where every week we would
do like a three hour experiment
and then every week have to write up a
long lab report and send that in it
would be about 10 or so
pages with all the code and everything
and
yeah i guess a few of the weeks of this
course i did have to pull an all-nighter
to get that lab report done
but yeah i managed to do well in it in
the end probably my favorite course this
year was math 203 linear algebra
which i also got an a plus in and i
don't know it was just a concept i
enjoyed i thought the lectures were
nice everything sort of fit together and
made sense in a way and
yeah i had a it was an area of math that
i felt like i was good at
during 2014 i did still have a lot of
stuff going on
outside class i was the vice president
of the physics society that year and
still working on i guess lots of little
science communication projects
but i think compared to the the previous
semester things were a lot more calm
i was in general less stressed and a bit
more organized
my third and final year i again made the
odd choice
to take ten courses instead of eight
and this time i did all of the usual
courses
in maths and physics and then i added on
this psych 106 course which i was able
to take under this program the uni had
called the vice
chancellor's award where people were
able to take
a course outside of their usual program
for me that would be outside of physics
and take it without having to pay for it
and they would only be marked either
pass or fail
so it wouldn't really affect their gpa
and they would be able to have
a try of something a little bit new so i
took this psychology course
and yeah i kind of enjoyed it my hardest
course this semester was math 302
and partial differential equations which
i got another b
in which again i wasn't happy about but
um
yeah that course i don't know i just
found it really hard
the mid-term test of this course i
actually got
50 on after getting that really bad
midterm result
i was like man i'm going to do terribly
in this course i should
withdraw from it because i've got way
more than enough points that i need to
graduate
i don't even need to take it but i went
to the admin of the university and they
said i was one day too late to be able
to withdraw from the course so i just
had to stay in it
and i guess i'm glad i did there would
have been you know no real benefit to me
pulling out of things even if i'm going
to get a low grade which might look bad
on my transcript
well at the time i didn't think i'd be
showing it to thousands of people on the
internet
but i guess it was better to just keep
it and learn the things i did learn in
that course than trying to run away from
it
that year i also did dynamical systems
which i really liked
it's one of my favorite courses but
definitely the course i loved the most
of my whole degree
was this course math 380 and it was
mathematics and perspective
it was basically a history of
mathematics class
it was in this course that i first read
a mathematician's apology
and the first time i encountered
babylonian
ancient mathematics and ideas there i
just
really loved everything in this course
one of the lecturers even gave us a
challenge
to present a mathematical poem to the
class
and at this time i'd already been
performing some mathematically themed
poems
at open mic nights around the city and
so that was like
right up my alley uh for an as for an
assignment that was exactly the things i
love doing
and i was quite proud of myself for
getting a few a-pluses
and subjects that i'd found were quite
difficult including
the advanced experimental physics the
classical mechanics and symmetry
principles
and the advanced electromag and
materials course
and so that was more than enough to
graduate with a bachelor of science
first major physics second major
mathematics
and i have at the end here some academic
awards that i had while i was a student
i did also receive the award for a top
physics student at the end of my third
year
and one of the reasons i came to this
university was that i got the aurora
scholarship in astronomy
and that was something that you applied
for coming out of school
and it allowed you to go to the mount
john
university observatory and do like
experience
and observing and astronomy and i even
got to
take a trip to some overseas astronomy
sites as part of that so that was
really great and yeah i'd done quite a
lot of astronomy stuff
including at my local astronomy club as
a high school student so that definitely
helped
in applying for that after this degree i
moved to australia
and went to the anu where i did my
honours year and started my phd
and i guess i've never shown these
grades to anyone except having to apply
for honors and phd
and since then you know they haven't
really been needed at all
and um i guess i probably didn't need to
worry
so much about what they looked like in
that case because
no one really is going to be looking
back to these grades
as you you know finish higher degrees
and and go into the workforce
although i'm in the unique position of
showing them now to thousands of people
which probably would have been
my worst fear when i got some of those
grades i didn't like
but yeah i guess it's important
though to mention that i spent a lot of
time stressing
about how these grades would look and
how they would be perceived and
maybe linking my self-worth to these
grades
which is not a good thing to do i don't
regret getting good grades though
because it meant that i was trying
really hard at these courses and i was
actually learning a lot of things
while i was a student i didn't really go
out i didn't drink
i didn't party and you might consider
that to be a
sacrifice in striving for good grades
to me i didn't really see it as a
sacrifice because
those weren't things that i was
interested in or would enjoy
anyway but there were certain sacrifices
for sure that i had to make
just to my own life to try this hard and
to
you know want to want to get these
grades that looked good i also wouldn't
consider my efforts here to be
wasted now that i'm not doing my phd and
now that i'm making youtube videos
maybe one day i will return to the phd
but it's
you know not something that i really
feel is right for me at the moment
and i don't consider these grades
haven't gone to waste
because i can always you know take that
option to go back
or i can just take this knowledge and
experience that i got in the process
and use it to do other things in the
meantime you can expect to see me
covering the grades and other documents
from people who are much more impressive
than myself
and a big thank you for helping me to
reach 500k
subscribers it's an awesome milestone
and
you know definitely every one of you who
has subscribed to the channel
has helped me get there a big thank you
as always
to my patreon supporters and a special
shout out to
today's patron cat of the day who is
looking awfully reptilian
thor thanks for watching and i hope to
see you next time